did you guys hear what Trump just
announced you know there's a lot of
right-wing Christians out there who
think that Trump is out here to be our
Messiah he's GNA save the day he's gonna
stop the New World Order and he's got
the plan right I know I know you guys
know these people heard of these people
maybe you're one of these people let me
tell you you do not get to that position
of President of the United States the
world power
unless you are a part of the club and if
you know what I'm talking about the club
is not a club that you're a part of it's
the the elites of the world that have
they have a plan they have an agenda and
whether they are making the moves or
they are just Pawns in the game they do
not have any power the president is just
the face of this thing where Satan is
pulling the strings if you believe in
the Bible like I do then you are a
conspiracy theorist I hate to tell you
that but it's just the truth because we
believe that there is an invisible War a
spiritual warfare going on that's going
to bring about a one world religious
system a One World Government a one
world religion that is soon to come I
believe it's coming way sooner than we
ever thought in the past and when I look
into like esoteric writings and the
Occult writings such as Alice Bailey and
she was talking about um in her
channeled writing writings predicting
that
2025 would be the age of Aquarius and
the time when there'd be the the um
externalization of the hierarchy
literally demon Spirits
manifesting in this world and then
there's an agenda called project
2025 that says the next Republican
leader has the power to be like a
dictator like a religious dictator
whatever law he wants to put in it's
going to happen and it's going to be
religious in nature and it's going to
bring this nation back to God because
the pendulum has been swinging far left
for a couple years and that's that's not
a secret everybody can see that this
world is in utter chaos it's Babylon
confusion we don't know if you're male
or female uh there's no laws to anything
it's completely lawlessness but for the
Antichrist to step on the scene it has
to be chaos because this is what this is
how these people work it's order out of
chaos this is how Satan Works he causes
the problem and then offers the solution
so when there's fires and earthquakes
and floods all over the place in places
you wouldn't expect and then there's all
this
chaos there has to be a savior we are we
are on the brink even the left is sick
of this even people like Joe Rogan are
saying Jesus if you're real go ahead and
come now because like this world needs
help this is the stage being set
perfectly for Satan to come out as
Christ so check out this clip if you
guys haven't seen it this is Trump
giving a speech and listen to the
terminology listen to the words that he
says because this is prophetic we have
before us a rare
opportunity to bring security and
stability and peace to this region and
to its people did you hear some Choice
words there I heard a a a a
phrase security and peace security and
peace I think those are interesting
phrases because when you look in the
Bible in Thessalon 1 Thessalonians 5:3
it says for when they shall say peace
and safety sudden destruction cometh
upon them as travail upon a woman with
child and they shall not Escape when you
read the context of 1 Thessalonians 5:3
for yourselves know perfectly that the
day of the Lord so come as a thief in
the night the context of this is Christ
is coming soon in this time he's giving
the context Christ is coming when all
this happens for when they shall say
peace and SA safety then sudden
destruction cometh upon them as travail
upon a woman with child and they shall
not Escape so if you're someone who
believes in the pre-tribulation Rapture
there's a video on our Channel check it
out it's a response to that and when you
look at any verse about the Rapture it's
always the second coming notice this
says it
says when they say peace and safety
sudden destruction comes it doesn't say
a Rapture is going to happen and then s
years later there's going to be
destruction anytime you see this phrase
a thief in the night the other ones in
first or second Peter and it says the
same thing for the day of the Lord shall
come as a thief in the night in the
which the heavens and the Earth shall
pass away with a great noise and the
elements shall melt with fervent heat
there's no seven years of tribulation
there's no time period where the
Christians are sucked off the Earth and
then all hell breaks for seven years it
doesn't happen so I'm only telling you
this because the truth will set you free
and we need to know that we're not going
to be sucked out of here but guess what
we will be protected through a lot of
things I'm not saying that we won't be
martyred even Christ himself was
martyred all his followers were martyred
Jesus himself said in this life you will
have much tribulation that you will be
delivered up by your friends and your
brothers to be killed for my name's sake
that's a promise from Jesus Christ
himself but what I'm saying is when we
are here during the tribulation the
plagues being poured upon the Earth we
will not be affected by those plagues
just like the Israelites were not
affected by the plagues that were
reported upon Egypt right the frogs came
the blood was there the firstborn child
would die the egyp the Israelites were
not affected by those plagues they were
protected and we will be protected as
well not to say that we will not have
tribulation that is a lie that is a
false Doctrine so I just think that's
interesting that Trump literally said
these words peace and safety he said
security and peace it's the same thing
and uh I believe the stage is being set
check out this news
clip president Trump's first full day
back in office included a major
announcement about artificial
intelligence that will bring jobs to
Texas the president stood next to the
CEOs of open AI Oracle and soft Bank to
announce a $500 billion doll project
called Stargate the project would build
new data centers and electricity
generation needed to power AI Texas will
serve as a launch point with the first
of the data centers being built in abene
the goal for Stargate is to create
100,000 new jobs here in the United
States the goal goal is to create a
100,000 jobs
now ai is really taking away jobs if
you've heard any of these interviews
with Elon Musk and stuff you know
self-driving cars are going to take away
jobs from Uber drivers and delivery
people and um if you're a screenwriter
or a musician or a a a translator or a
narrator your jobs are gone even if you
are an artist a lot of your jobs are
being taken away by AI so is actually
going to remove jobs even Cashers no
longer exist anymore you got one or two
people at Walmart watching 20 cash
registers and you are the employee as
you scan all your products technology is
actually removing jobs but they're
saying that this AI uh surveillance
system called Oracle which is an
interesting name and it's also called
Stargate Stargate if you look in the
Bible uh what is a symbol for Angels the
word star is a symbol for Angels so when
I hear this term Stargate I'm thinking
biblically are we making a gate for
angels to come through because not all
angels are good angels and I think we
might just be creating a portal for
Satan to enter into our world
interestingly enough Elon Musk has a
star link so we're linking up with
angels and we're creating gates for
Angels but maybe I'm looking too deep
into that what I think is interesting is
the name of this company is called
Oracle and it's an AI surveillance
company so if this is going to bring a
100,000 jobs what kind of jobs are you
going to have think about that we'll get
to that what kind of jobs are is this
going to offer I don't think it's going
to give you a job on a assembly line or
a you know a cash register or whatever
it's going to have to be you're going to
be working with surveillance so I just
think that's crazy omnipresent AI
cameras will en ensure good behavior
says Larry Ellison he is the guy who is
the owner the the CEO the founder of
Oracle who is bringing out this Stargate
AI surveillance omnipresent like these
this terminology this is what Satan
wants he wants to be God he's already
the God of this world the Bible says
that we see all the evil in the world
he's the one that offered Jesus all the
kingdoms of the world he has the power
to do that but omnipresent AI cameras
this is saying that no nobody is going
to be unseen at any time is that ever a
good I mean this is insane this is
dystopian
1984 uh Brave New World Logan's Run like
this is all those crazy movies about
these dystopian worlds are coming true
right now
I mean this is the year
2025 Fortune did an article on him it
says Larry Ellison predicts rise of the
modern surveillance State interesting
surveillance state where citizens will
be on their best behavior this is crazy
this is absolutely insane they're saying
we need to just make we need to force
people to be good by watching every move
they
make there's a part of me and others
that hey that does sound kind of good
but you this is a heart condition like
for people to truly have a change they
need to be repentant they need to know
the truth that Christ has come to set
them free that they can be filled with
the Holy Spirit and that they can live
as a new creature in Christ but forcing
people to be good through surveillance
you're talking about creating humanoid
robots at this point that no longer have
free will they're just
obeying because out of fear complete
fear this is going to be a fear-based
system here which is completely opposite
of God uh check out this news clip this
guy Larry's gonna talk and tell you what
he predicts this AI surveillance is
going to do for the
world Oracle co-founder Larry Ellison
predicts AI surveillance will be part of
our everyday lives in the future during
a recent Oracle Q&A Ellis said AI will
soon play a major role in monitoring
Society through a vast network of
interconnected cameras including
security systems police body cams and
vehicle dash cams everyone would see it
your your your body cams will be
transmitting that the police will be on
their best behavior because we Rec we're
constantly recording watching and
recording everything that's going on
citizens will be on their best behavior
because we're constantly recording and
Reporting everything that's going on
Ellison's vision is for AI to analyze
data from this network of cameras in
real time in an attempt to prevent crime
while also tracking and influencing
public behavior for a safer Society
however the idea raises serious privacy
concerns critics argue it could lead to
a surveillance state with constant
monitoring infringing on personal
privacy rights While others say it could
help solve crimes faster and provide
transparency to citizens cases of
excessive force from law enforcement
we're going to have supervision other
words every police officer is going to
be
supervised at all times Ellison's
proposal highlights a growing Trend
among Tech Giants to harness AI for
societal influence which may
significantly reshape our lives in the
coming years this is completely insane I
mean this is surveillance State Police
State I don't think it's a coincidence
that there there are massive amounts of
drones flying in our skies all over the
place and the military is like we don't
know what they are but don't worry it's
it's all good they're not harmful just
go on with life they are unrolling the
police state right now the surveillance
state right before a very eyes and we're
all just asleep we're like yeah go for
it like I don't I don't know what it is
but it's all good uh the media told me
it's safe so I'm going to believe that
if you don't remember I did a video
about the UN saying that they were going
to do they were going to uh create AI
governance they signed this new law that
nobody voted on I didn't vote on this
where it was talking about AI governance
and there was people in the comments
that were saying I think you're getting
this wrong I think they're talking about
they're going to govern AI but no this
is exactly what I was saying was going
to happen was that AI is going to be
governing us we the people are going to
be governed by AR icial intelligence
computers we are no longer the highest
on the totem pole anymore we're not the
top of the pyramid it is now ai playing
God the allseeing omnipresent eyes in
the sky that are watching every move you
make this is a position that only God
should have but right now artificial
intelligence is getting that position
and they're spending tons amount of
money on it so what is is this going to
like what good could this cause what bad
could this cause let's say the good
is maybe a woman can walk down the
street now without feeling that she
might be harmed in some way that's good
maybe if there's a wreck you could see
who's at fault if there's a crime you
could see who's at
fault but this is going to lead to
something terrible this is going to lead
to pre-crime where they're predicting
what you do they're going to be AI is
going to be analyzing everything every
post you make that is a little bit
critical of the government
or maybe
um you didn't go to church on the day
that you were supposed to go to church
because now there's a a new law about
worship remember in Revelation it says
that they worshiped the Beast and His
Image and if those who did not would be
killed
first they would have their ability to
buy and sell cut off then they would be
thrown in prison 10 days and finally
they would be beheaded this is prophecy
and so when you have a system like this
that's watching every move you make it
canot only help us to solve crimes but
it's also going to help Satan persecute
those who do not worship the Beast
according to his law if you don't
Worship in this way you will be killed
this is the technology that's going to
make that possible now China's been
doing something for a while called
social credit scores check this out
everywhere she goes o Yang Hau is
followed what she buys how she behaves
is tracked and scored to show how
responsible and trustworthy she is it's
called the social credit system and in
one version now being tested a person's
reputation is scored on a scale of 350
to 950 and how you with a good score of
752 is okay with it in fact most people
are it's a mechanism like uh pushes you
to become a better citizen it's big data
meets Big Brother expanding how the
government monitors understands and
ultimately controls its 1.4 billion
citizens thanks to advances in
artificial intelligence and facial
recognition and a web of more than 200
million surveillance cameras are people
bothered by privacy concerns we think uh
the lot of
Cameron keep the safety is really good
we can accept it companies are
experimenting with the algorithms to
help the government create the new
National social credit system the
government also has pilot projects in
one citizens are required to do hours of
unpaid work to get benefits and scores
are docked for things like littering a
messy yard gossip even
walking video of offenders is shown on
the local
news and information collectors like Jo
I are paid to report on their neighbors
her quota 10 entries a
month like the man who carried a drunk
person home a good deed she says good
social credit gets rewarded with perks
like cheap loans and travel deals but a
bad score means public shame and worse
hangu Jun lost a court case and didn't
pay now he's on a government Black List
I can't buy airplane or train tickets he
says and the list goes on being
discredited makes it hard to get a job
or put kids in top schools the social
credit system will go Nationwide next
year and few here are willing to
criticize it something that may pose a
risk itself for a bad score and the life
that comes with it Janice Macky frer NBC
News Beijing Hey NBC News fans thanks
for checking out our yoube Chanel
subscri by clicking on that button down
you watch
Terminator something I used to be a huge
fan of Terminator look at this
Skynet oh my goodness it is not sci-fi
anymore every sci-fi movie is coming
true right now this is I cannot believe
that so this video was from like five
years ago four years ago something like
that can you imagine if we were living
in that right now where everything you
do is scored whether you littered
whether you jaywalked whether you ran a
red light whether you did a good deed
like carried a drunk person home this
guy said that he couldn't buy or sell
because his credit score was too low and
what affects your credit score your good
works your good
behavior that might even sound okay but
who is the judge of what is good and
what is wrong is it the Ten Commandments
or is it a
totalitarian dictatorship of Elites that
are saying this is what makes a good
citizen if you do this you are good if
you do this you are bad if you do not
bow to the Beast system think about
Nebuchadnezzar if you don't bow to the
image you're bad and you get thrown into
the fire that was a long time ago this
is going to repeat history repeats
itself prophecy is coming true and if
you don't Worship in this way you won't
be able to buy or sell and imagine the
pressure that's going to put on you as
you begin to starve and as you watch
your family starve this is going to be
the biggest deception in human history
this is going to be the biggest test of
God's people in human history because
it's going to be on a worldwide scale
this is going to be something that's
never been done the Bible talks about
that those who survive through the
tribulation we will be singing a new
song that no one else can sing you know
why because nobody has been through this
experience that we are going to be going
through this is a time of testing like
no other like we need to be praying for
God to give us the strength Supernatural
strength that we've never had it's time
to stop letting creeping compromise come
into our lives where we're just giving
allowance to this sin or that sin or
I'll ignore that this is the time this
is the time to take our relationship
serious guys we need a relationship with
God like never before so if you don't
remember there was a time when covid was
first happening and they were really
serious about everybody wearing masks I
remember this clip being a New York clip
this is another guy it says in Downtown
LA listen to what he says we need to
make sure that everybody continues to
let us know where those folks are if
you've observed recurring violations of
the safer at home order please continue
to let us know at coronav virus. La
city.org buus violation you know the old
expression about snitches well in this
case snitches get rewards we want to
thank you for turning folks in and
making sure we are all safe it used to
be snitches get stitches but now it's
snitches get rewards this was starting
four or five years ago when Corona was
first rising up right I remember New
York saying the same thing he said
snitches get rewards that lady in China
was saying that she's a hired a hired
citizen to be a
snitch you're not going to be able to
trust your neighbor this is what Jesus
said he said brother will turn against
brother like you won't be able to trust
your family your friends and this is why
it's so important for us to have a
relationship with Christ because there's
coming a time when we can't depend on
anyone no one but Christ Alone to help
us through to to get us through this
time of trouble your own spouse may turn
completely on you and and go for the
Beast system because it seems easier you
cannot let that turn you from keeping
what God Said from keeping God's
Commandments Revelation says blessed are
those who keep the Commandments of God
that they may have right to the tree of
life and may enter into the gates of
into the city three times Revelation
says blessed are they that do his
Commandments this is what the test is
all about it's about not bowing to a
government system of worship but keeping
God's Commandments at all cost Shadrach
mesach and abedo would not even simply
bow their bodies before an image a
simple act as that sounds it's breaking
the second commandment they said we will
not bow to your image you can throw in
the fire do we have that courage we have
to have this kind of Courage we need to
be begging God for the courage to be
like
that so here's Larry Ellison I I'm
showing this because he's the owner of
Oracle I think that's an interesting
title for a company because Oracle means
a priest or Priestess acting as a medium
through whom advice or prophecy
was sought from the gods in class
classic Antiquity look at
this this is the name of the company
that is going to be
omnipresent Godlike
surveillance from AI watching every move
you make forcing people to be good
citizens as he said Oracle the priest a
medium of the classic
Gods I just think that is so telling
everything is so predictive programming
this is just right in your face I can't
believe I can't believe we're in the
time that we're in Revelation 13:17 says
and and that no man might buy or sell
save he that had the Mark or the name of
the Beast or the number of his name so
many people get hung up on this one
verse they'll take this one verse and
say you know what this this means it's a
microchip because if you don't have it
if you don't take it you can't buy or
sell the issue is about worship it's not
about a form of currency we're already
in a cashless Society hardly anyone even
takes cash anymore you don't have to
have a microchip implant for the
government to be able to shut off your
ability to buy or sell if you don't
remember when there was uh these
Trucking protests in Canada anyone who
was caught bringing a can of gas to
those Truckers had their bank account
Frozen this already happened no
microchip required even in the past in
the
1600s they had a law that if you did not
go to church every Sunday morning and
evening your ability to buy and sell
would be cut off I'm going to look it up
right now because I just I want people
to know this stuff there's so much
deception out there today I found out is
the website it's not a Christian website
this is just history um blue laws check
this out when you read this it says what
are blue laws if you come down to this
second paragraph it says the first blue
law although not called that at the time
was enacted in colonial Virginia in
1610 and it mandated Church attendance
at both morning and afternoon services
on Sundays a first time offender lost
his provision and allowance for a whole
week so if you don't wor worship this
way that the government says you will
not be able to buy or sell that's
already happened this did not require a
microchip implant it's about punishment
it's about punishing those who do not
worship and go against God's
Commandments because the fourth
Commandment says remember the Sabbath
day to keep it holy but man and Satan
says no you will keep the venerable day
of the Sun and you must do it by force
not by free will will it says those who
committed a second offense in addition
to losing his allowance so you still
can't buy or sell would be whipped so
here we have
persecution then it says a third
violation was supposedly punished by
death though there are is debate over
whether accounts of early blue laws in
some cases were exaggerated or not you
know why I think they don't know for a
fact I bet hardly anyone if any one got
to a third offense I think it
was
so easy to compromise go to church on
Sunday every morning and evening no
problem I'll do that I don't want to
lose my allowance and I don't want to be
whipped and I sure don't want to die
that was the Compromise made in the
1600s no microchip required if you want
to find out more there's a a link on in
this YouTube channel called who is the
Beast and what is his Mark or it's
called uh mark of the beast not a
microchip is 35 minutes scripture line
upon line comparing here a little there
a Little by the mouth of two or three
Witnesses we can't make
entire belief systems out of one verse
taken out of context this one verse does
not mean that the Mark is a form of
currency but rather The Bu the ability
to have your buying and selling turned
off is a form of punishment for not
worshiping the way that the Beast system
tells you to
so check out the video Global AI
governance 2030 they're they're saying
by 2030 the whole world is going to be
governed by
AI that can't happen overnight they're
putting the system in like if you
thought this was crazy it's already
happening Trump's already announcing it
that we invested uh a hundred billion
dollars into this thing and it's going
to happen so check out that video for
anyone that was a skeptic what that
meant it's happening now this was the
United Nations passing this stuff also
there was a video that I did on uh AI
technology lets prisoners serve time in
minutes so now if you do some heinous
crime and they'll give you an option do
you want to spend 10 years in prison or
do you want us to use AI in your brain
and you will feel like you served 10
years but it's only going to be a matter
of minutes
they have the technology to make you
believe that you've spent 10 years in
prison imagine the the form of torture
they can do with this
technology have you ever had a a nap you
took a nap and you had a dream and you
woke up and you're like oh man I had
this crazy dream I was doing this and
this and people were like somebody said
uh you were only asleep for like five
minutes it's like no like this thing
felt like days that's because in your
brain in your mind you can manipulate
time and they're doing it with AI
technology already they're they're
giving you the option to take your
sentence in minutes instead of
years also all this stuff rolling out
the drones that are coming out that
they're saying we don't know what they
are check out that video because this is
not just mysterious drones out there I
do believe that they are getting us
immune to things being in the sky and
they're like oh we don't know what it is
but don't worry it's not harmful just go
about life as usual and they'll unroll
the drones that are going to be
surveying us Sur surveillancing us all
the time but some of these are just
spiritual demonic entities people are
zooming in on these things and they are
not drones they are pulsating orbs
they're getting us used to the idea of
things flying around the sky that we
don't know what they are why because
Satan in the last days is going to bring
about this alien deception and he's
going to come as a cosmic Christ and say
I have all the answers to your problems
I can heal you I can get rid of
pandemics I can fix climate change and
we are going to fall for it because
we're going to say well if this being
was evil wouldn't they have already
destroyed us wouldn't they have already
caused us harm they've been here all
this time for years and have never
caused us harm and maybe even have done
good things like deactivate nukes and
things like that that they say these
things do
also check out the video about the the
fires because these fires were not
natural for one and for another they've
already had a system set up where they
want to turn La into a smart city by
2028 I don't think it's a coincidence
that La is now leveled and ready to be
built back better as they say this is
predictive programming they've been
putting this in all kinds of
entertainment Joe Biden was saying this
we're gonna build back better and all
this this is all order out of chaos this
is cause the problem and bring about the
solution it's going to look good you're
going to feel like the government's on
your side while they're building your
enslavement camp this is what's coming
The Simpsons are always predicting
things right this was season 28 which
started in the year
2015 and ended in
2017 and this is how it starts
[Music]
what do you see on the screen right
now well there's an alien a UFO there's
a banner that is definitely a nod to
Trump make the universe great again so
is Trump in office now yes are we seeing
things flying around the sky yes okay
that's a very interesting scene right
here on the
screen now they unveiled this
statue that's highly
reflective and the Sun hits the statue
and begins to cause these
fires isn't this an interesting scene
the Eds extinguisher store just closed
yesterday if you watch the video that I
did on the fires there's interviews with
people who are saying Insurance stopped
covering fires 6 months before the fires
happen this
none of the water worked everybody was
trying to turn on their water hoses and
none of the water was working firemen
couldn't even get water so I think it's
really crazy that this show that's known
for predictive programming back in
2015 was predicting that a laser and
okay you might be saying that's not a
laser that's the sun reflecting but in
this Scene It is a
laser that beam just cured these
people's eyesight and it says laser eye
surgery so they're telling you that this
is a laser that is burning down a
city and there are things burnt up but
there's something blue standing there if
you look into this topic you'll realize
that lasers don't burn blue blue fabric
blue rubber blue paint all that's talked
about in that La fire video there's
there's there's videos out there of
people shooting lasers at a blue balloon
and it doesn't pop blue fabric it
doesn't burn blue paint doesn't burn
there's different frequencies of lasers
but the ones that are most common seem
to be the ones that don't affect blue
and here's this blue tarp standing there
I think that's very
symbolic you see everything smoking we
will rebuild we will rebuild we will
rebuild isn't that interesting this came
out in 2020 or 2015
Joe Biden who said build back better
wasn't even in office so this show
predicted Fires at a place that looks
like
Hollywood isn't that interesting Fires
at a place that looked like Hollywood
that was a laser that said the fire
extinguishers just closed yesterday but
guess what we're going to build back
better we will rebuild and that's what
Biden said when Biden came in office in
2021 much later after the episode of
this aired in
2015 and Joe Biden had this thing
about build back better that was the
slogan that he was coining that was his
catchphrase to build back
better if you look it up you'll see this
La Smart City smart La 2028 there's this
whole document that you can look at
where they have a plan to make La a
smart city by
2028 and now because people are catching
on there's all this propaganda coming
out saying oh la wildfires deliberately
started to turn Los Angeles into a smart
city by 2028 bizarre claim surfaces so
there's multiple news sources that are
saying oh the conspiracy theorists are
out again and they're trying to say that
this wasn't natural and all this stuff
but people like me and others out there
who are analyzing things we're not just
making things up we don't want to just
believe this stuff we're looking at the
evidence why are buildings completely
turned to rubble and yet there's green
trees and grass all around how come
things are vaporized but blue objects
are still around how come it's
coincidentally that the city burnt down
right before they want to turn it into a
smart city so this is just looking at
the
evidence and this is the document smart
La 2028 and I was wondering who who is
doing these smart cities Hatachi so I
looked up well has Hatachi done anything
with these smart cities yet and it says
Hatachi is currently building smart
cities in various locations around the
world here's one of them Maui islands in
Hawaii do you remember what happened to
the Maui Islands just a year or two ago
two years ago maybe they burnt down look
they turned Maui Hawaii into a smart
city so now we're connecting the dots
Again by the way there was all those
same characteristics of Maui buildings
being vaporized there's not even a
chimney or a a refrigerator or any kind
of metal appliance that car windshields
are melted and their rims are melting
into the streets and yet a blue umbrella
survives and all the greenery around
survives this is curious right it makes
you wonder what's going on and now that
very place has turned to a Smart City
well again another city has the same
character traits and there's already a
plan to make it a smart city by 2028 I
think it's a strange connection that in
2028 the Olympics are going to be held
we have a video on the Olympics Look up
the video the pagan origins of the
Olympics right on their Olympics website
this not even conspiracy theory it's
just history the Olympics are a a Greek
and Roman ritual it's a pagan ritual and
they openly admit it that these are
games to the gods and so it's all about
this death and rebirth and Rising
Phoenix out of the ashes and that's
going to be that event that ritual of
Rising Phoenix out of the ashes is going
to be happening in LA in 2028 when it's
going to be a smart city I don't think
this is a coincidence this is all set up
now listen to what this guy said my
first piece of advice to you is let's
take care of our mental and physical
health first before we Embark upon what
is going to be a journey to rebuild
these communities back and rebuild them
better than they were when we started
this
fire okay so there's two interesting
things that were said there the audio is
kind of low but the captions are on
there and he's talking about that we're
going to build back better again he's
putting this coin phrase out there
pushing it in your brain build back
better and then he
said before we started these fires
before we started these fires if you
didn't catch that it's on screen right
here when we started this fire listen to
this this is a Freudian slip these
communities back and rebuild them better
than they were when we started this fire
and build them back better when we
started this
fire is it all just a coincidence is all
this just some crazy
coincidence I I think you're more of a
conspiracy theorist when you think that
all of this is a coincidence than just
accepting the facts that's that's what I
believe and so here's Vox saying it's a
make or break moment for housing in
California the future of the state
depends on how leaders rebuild after the
Los Angeles f
I get it the the fires destroyed homes
and you're definitely going to have to
rebuild I just think it's crazy that in
2015 all that predictive programing was
put in there that when Biden was in
office he was pushing this propaganda
this brainwashing slogan of build back
better this guy on the news said build
back better when we started these fires
if this was eye openening to you please
click a thumbs up it really helps get
this message out to the world gets this
channel out there so more people can see
what's going on in the world that we are
living in the last days I believe it
without a shadow of a doubt we are
seeing things like we've never seen
before and soon we're going to be being
governed by AI artificial
intelligence Eye in the Sky uh
omnipresent surveillance and it's going
to force us to be good citizens isn't
that going to be fun to live in a
dystopian world like that but the good
news is Jesus is coming soon we have to
be ready ready I'm so ready for him to
come and to live in a truly perfect
world where there's no more pain and no
more sorrow if you are looking forward
to that day too please click a thumbs up
please say Amen in the comment section I
love you guys I thank you so much for
being here if you want to support this
channel you can do so by going to candid
truth.org there's a donate button you
can send a cash app vinmo zel PayPal we
cannot do this without you this is our
fulltime job and if we don't have
supporters like you we have to go back
to work if you like t-shirts we got some
cool t-shirts you can find those on
candid truth.org we got uh just some
really cool slogans as well as scripture
shirts and I'm wearing one of them right
now be cool use your brain it's cool to
use your brain Satan doesn't want you to
think the militaries of the world don't
want you to think because guess what a
thinking population is harder to control
so it's cool to use your brain don't
fall for the propaganda I love you guys
God bless and we'll see you next time on
candid truth